[Music]
what's up everyone i'm sydney goodman
and i will be your host
awards 2019 pre-show the game awards
will begin at the top of the hour
featuring musical performances by green
day grimes and churches and brand new
looks at ghosts of tsushima and gears
tactics but while the microsoft theater
fills in behind me and the world gets
their popcorn ready we've got 30 minutes
of awards special guests and world
premieres of our own right here in the
pre-show including a brand new trailer
for final fantasy 7 remake
but there is
no better way for us to kick off than by
handing out our first trophy of the
night and this is a special one the game
awards have a new category this year to
honor the teams that honor their
community the best community support
award goes to a game that listens reacts
and responds to its players with honest
respect and transparency the nominees
for best community support are
apex legends
[Applause]
destiny 2
final fantasy 14
fortnite
and rainbow six siege
and the winner is
[Applause]
destiny 2
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations thank you very much this
is a
this is really an honor i i got to
acknowledge the people at bungie who've
worked so hard to you know support our
community starting with our community
team who are on the front lines every
day interacting with our fans the core
development team our operations folks
like everyone up and down just cares so
much about this game and
i just i got to acknowledge all their
hard work
the only thing i'd add is everyone here
creates entertainment and what use is
creating entertainment if you don't have
awesome fans so special thanks to our
fans
that's amazing well congratulations
again thank you so much thank you
huge congratulations to destiny 2 for
winning our first ever best community
support award i'm sure it's no
coincidence they are also up for best
ongoing game later tonight now the game
awards is a show about celebrating all
of gaming more than just the winners
throughout the night you'll see
unexpected additions to games you love
check-ins on games you're anticipating
and reveals you never saw coming here's
the first of many world premieres
[Applause]
[Music]
i can sense a great cosmic disturbance
we must be prepared for the worst time
to change history for the better
[Music]
hey someone's got to be the coolest guy
in the room
[Music]
oh this is going to be fun just you wait
[Music]
do you have any idea who you're up
against
[Music]
welcome to the danger room
i hope you survive the experience
[Music]
the phoenix force has reawakened i will
cleanse this world with my flames
[Music]
in 2018 the game awards teamed up with
facebook gaming to honor global gaming
citizens people from all areas of gaming
who use the power of games to create a
positive influence tonight i'm joined by
one of the global gaming citizens we met
last year who has a new project to show
us please welcome lual mayan thank you
so much thank you so much yeah
so luau what have you been working on
yeah for sure you know as someone from
uh africa and also as a refugee i want
to thank everybody that has been
supporting me to come up with a game
today facebook gaming eisenberg and
walden i've been working on a game that
actually put a player in the choose of a
refugee it's a game that actually talk
about journey and helping people to
understand the empathy and this is
something that video game can be able to
do around the world we can be able to
change the world and help people around
the world and see what whatever they're
going through through playing video game
so it's a game really that put a player
in the shoes of refugees and breaching
the reality wall and the and what is
actually happening on the ground so i'm
really so excited about the project
incredible well let's take a look yeah
sure thank you
i created salam because games are very
powerful to to create empathy and to
help people understand the journey of a
refugee growing up in a refugee camp my
mother spent three years looking for
three hundred dollars to buy a computer
then i told myself how to create a video
game my mission in creating salaam is to
let the world know what it's like to be
a refugee when you buy medicine and food
in the game it goes to real refugees
refugees like me
together we can take small steps to make
a big difference
it's so great to show you games like
salaam we have such a unique opportunity
here at the game awards to shine our
spotlight on games big and small look
forward to seeing some more interesting
indies later tonight
this next game awards category also
demonstrates this kind of diversity in
gaming the nominees represent completely
different budgets nationalities and
genres but they all share one thing
excellent music here are the nominees
for best score in music
cadence of hyrule
[Applause]
death stranding
devil may cry 5.
kingdom hearts 3
and sayonara wild hearts
and the winner is
death stranding
[Applause]
wow
what is going on
i don't know what's there i like your
colors oh my gosh thank you so much i
like your colors as well how are you
feeling i'm i've been nervous this whole
week and i can't believe this is
happening right now i just want to say
big thanks and shout out and also a
congratulations to lore churches and
southern poets for helping us making
this soundtrack as versatile as it
ended up being i'm just super happy to
be here and i'm super thankful for all
the fans who
inspired us to do something super weird
and i hope we can keep on doing weird
[ __ ] going forward
i think we all hope that
congratulations thank you
for the past two e3s there's been one
game featured in the pc gaming show that
continues to fill our imagination with
endless possibilities i'm talking of
course about man eater the game where
you are a killer shark that eats people
if you're hungry for more man-eater
here's a new world premiere
[Music]
humans kill 100 million sharks every
year
but only five humans are killed by
shovels
it's time to even the score
[Music]
eat
explore
evolve
not everybody may be a fisherman
it's shark versus men
man eater
stephen curry will be here tonight to
award the best esports player of 2019
but for now i have the honor of
acknowledging the winners for some
esports categories
for best esports coach the nominees are
adrian kane
grabs
coma
soksha
and zonic
and the winner
is
sonic
for best esports event the nominees are
the 2019 overwatch league grand finals
evo 2019
fortnite world cup
iem karovichi 2019
league of legends world championship
2019
and the international 2019.
and the winner is
league of legends world championship
2019.
for best esports host the nominees are
shocks
machine
red eye
golden boy
and candace
and the winner is
shocks
and for best esports team the nominees
are
astralis
g2 esports
og
san francisco shock
and team liquid
and the winner is
g2 esports
huge congratulations to all of the
winners now we'd like to take a moment
to say hi and what's up to everyone
watching the game awards live in movie
theaters across 50 cities where the game
awards are part of a special double
feature with jumanji the next level
we're about to take a short break but
first here's a little message from a
couple of the stars of jumanji the next
level
what's up game awards what's up
playstation we checked out dreams and
got to see the playstation versions of
ourselves it was trippy we're in a game
yeah no kidding especially your face yes
it was so
handsome would you look at me i'm back
no you can be the judge when you see it
for yourself you shouldn't have paused
like and we can't wait for you to see
jumanji the next level
i can't say this enough we're in a video
game
[Music]
we rise up
[Music]
me
[Music]
three two
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
clear your eyes
[Music]
nominees for 2019 gaming tweet of the
year
[Music]
welcome back to the game awards pre-show
this summer i had the pleasure of
joining jeff to co-host gamescom opening
night live and one of the games we
revealed that night was amplitude
studios humankind here to unveil a new
gameplay feature and the first trailer
with gameplay please welcome jeff spock
hi thanks cindy i'm
very excited and kind of terrified to be
here um i'm here to answer a question
we've been hearing constantly since we
announced the game this summer and the
question is
who am i playing am i playing a king a
queen historical figure leader of
civilization
tonight we can announce that you're
going to play
you the idea is that you're going to
create a highly customizable avatar that
will evolve visually as you play the
game so as you make game play decisions
as you win achievements as you select
cultures and that sort of thing
you'll see that evolve on the avatar
itself which means that at the end of
the game you'll have sort of a a record
and a trophy of how you changed
humankind
we have tons of ideas of where the
avatar system can go we're very excited
about it but if i talk about them the
programmers will literally disembowel me
when i get home
so in order to avoid that we put
together a trailer so we have a world
premiere
game experience and gameplay trailer to
showcase the humankind avatar system
beautiful why don't we take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
it all started way back
back to basics
ah
the good old days
gathering
hunting
and
well
back to gathering
we switched from a cold to a cool place
to settle and i found the perfect spot
for my people
at first it was just a few walls to keep
the bears out and the pigs in but you
know how it is one district led to
another and it kind of snowballed
now the problem was
the neighbors thought the grass was
greener on my side of the fence
but we saw them coming from a mile away
all i had to do was give the order
their first mistake
bringing infantry to a cavalry fight
next losing the high ground
final mistake not keeping up in the arms
race
but eventually peace prevailed and we
came to an understanding
they surrendered and i let them live
it turns out we had a lot to learn from
them and together we became more than
the sum of our parts a unique mix of
cultures and beliefs so yeah i would say
i left my mark on humankind and i'm just
getting started
but that's just my story
tell me what will yours be
[Music]
[Applause]
for our next world premiere this is
totally true by the way i'm not lying to
you they honestly haven't even told me
what it is yet so i am
just as in the dark as all of you right
now and i gotta say it's pretty exciting
i really have no clue what to expect
right now but we're all in this together
so let's all kick back and enjoy this
one
[Music]
damon i love you
best friends forever fool
it looks like this is goodbye food
in 20 years i will return
gopher
is that you
damon i love you
do it
apparently superheroes are popular in
this country so we're gonna jump on that
fight
what are you
i'm a goddamn superhero
[Music]
so there is an extended version
2020 release
good luck
[Music]
oh my gosh
okay well so right now we are streaming
all over the planet on over 50 different
platforms throughout the night we'll be
running polls for twitch audience to
predict categories like esports player
and ongoing game so stay tuned for them
if you're on tick tock you may have seen
we've been celebrating gaming the past
week with a special gaming on tick tock
challenge tonight use the gaming on tik
tok hashtag to show us how you're
celebrating video games biggest night
lastly we're shouting out the most
active game communities on reddit in
2019
fortnight vr
league of legends and destiny the game
but now i think it's time for another
world premiere
here's a brand new trailer for one of
next year's most anticipated games
final fantasy 7 remake
[Applause]
[Music]
look i'm involved in things
dangerous things
so
so keep your distance
what was his name again cloud cloud
strife this is a one-time gig
when it's done we're done
come on nobody do something this crazy
just for money
you gonna stand there and pretend you
can't hear the plan crying out in pain i
know you can
i'd worry less about the planet and more
about the next five seconds
okay that was pretty cool
you weren't thinking of leaving midgar
anytime soon were you
well seems this old friend of mine's in
a tight spot
a long time ago i made a promise so
[Music]
i'm really glad to have you back cloud
really glad
[Music]
before i hand the show over to jeff i
have the privilege of presenting one
more game award here in our pre-show
here are the nominees for best fighting
game
dead or alive six
jump force
[Applause]
mortal kombat 11
samurai showdown
and
super smash brothers ultimate
and the winner is
super smash brothers ultimate
[Music]
congratulations it's heavy
it is isn't it yeah thank you game
awards and thank you everyone out there
very very much you know super smash
brothers ultimate is really more than
just a fighting game it's an experience
that brings people together
it's also a showcase for some of the
most famous characters music
game worlds in video game history and
the fact that all of this comes together
so seamlessly and so beautifully is
really a testament to the dedication
to the hard work and to the skill of mr
sakurai and the development team this
award is for them thank you very very
much
congratulations
as you can see we are now just seconds
away from the start of the big show how
excited is everybody
the game awards orchestra is prepared
jeff keeley is buttoning up his tux and
everyone here in the live audience seems
ready to go
yeah let's hear it
it's going to be such a special show
green day
churches and grimes will all be
performing
there are a bunch of world premieres
that are going to amaze everyone and i
honestly have no idea who is going to
win game of the year
but
that's a wrap on our pre-show i'm sidney
goodman have fun and enjoy the show
the game awards starts right now
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
later
[Music]
at the end of time
[Music]
keep
[Music]
of
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Music]
maybe together we can make
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
nothing really
matters up
[Music]
you can take
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we
keep us together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we call the home
it's not the weapons i don't trust first
minister it's the people who use them
time's running out
[Music]
i need to fix this it can be beautiful
for terrible but we are all transfixed
i was waiting for you on the beach
you
are unfit to wear this crown
[Music]
we need your help dante
now please welcome your host and the
creator of the game awards
jeff keeley
good evening everyone
welcome to the game awards 2019 i'm jeff
keeley it is such an honor to be here
you guys ready to celebrate video games
tonight
i can't believe this is the fifth
anniversary of the show and it's so
great to have all of you here we've got
so many amazing special guests mr kojima
reggie mr miyazaki
it's it's so exciting to have everyone
here with us tonight to celebrate games
first of all let's give it up again for
churches and the game awards orca show
wasn't that beautiful
amazing
uh you know tonight
one of the things that really amazes me
about this show is how we connect the
world around games and we are live on
over 50 platforms around the world so i
want to say hello to everyone here but
also everyone watching around the world
if you're in europe i know it's late at
night thank you for staying up i think
we're going to make it worth your while
we've got a lot of cool surprises for
you tonight so
um millions people coming together all
to celebrate video games now our show
tonight
yes we're gonna have awards yes we're
gonna have a lot of brand new game
announcements and some surprises for you
so stay tuned for that
we know you like those and we've also
got performances by green day
and grimes so stay tuned it's been an
outstanding year for games but to kick
things off let's get to our first award
and right now let's bring out our first
presenter he is a screenwriter and
producer known for the dark knight and
also the co-creator of westworld please
welcome jonathan nolan
good evening i'm here to present the
award for best narrative
we talk a lot about narrative in
westworld where our guest characters
choose their own paths with branching
storylines that change based on their
actions it's an idea that we invented
all by ourselves you're welcome
the truth is in any given year if
someone asked me what the best
storytelling i saw that year was
my answer as often as not isn't a movie
it's not a show
it's a game
games like fallout bioshock half-life
red dead redemption
[Music]
all hugely influential on our work and
you can see the echoes of those games in
our show
evan rachel wood
everyone rachel wood's character delores
has more than a little in common with
elizabeth and bioshock infinite james
morrison's character teddy was of course
based on james morrison's character in
sonic the hedgehog
and of course i'd be remiss if i failed
to mention the dead of honor that ed
harris's character the man in black owes
to cuber
so it's a true honor for me to be here
tonight to recognize the amazing
thoughtful and groundbreaking work in
narrative this year here are the
nominees
best narrative
where is your
i'd like to tell you about a dream i had
last night
sam if we don't all come together again
humanity will not survive
in the great city there's a dead body
behind the hostel cafeteria
hungry for adventure our colony has a
place for everyone
and the winner is
disco elysium
[Applause]
tonight disco elysium always wins the
game award for best role playing game
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's absolutely surreal to be here
and um
honestly it makes me really speechless
but i definitely want to thank everyone
who believed that this game exists when
we first started talking about it
because a lot of people didn't
um and i want to thank
the industry for welcoming us it's been
absolutely amazing
and
of course i want to thank our fans who
really proved
that these kinds of
narrative games
have their space in this industry
and yeah thanks a lot
[Applause]
congratulations guys all right we have
such a big show ahead uh now i want to
mention right now on twitch we've got
over 900 000 concurrent viewers watching
the show right now including
co-streamers so
sounds like you guys are excited about
what we have going on and of course
we're live on over 50 platforms and the
fans on twitch are predicting who will
take home the game awards tonight right
now we've got a poll open with the
twitch extension who does the audience
think is going to win the best esports
player award you can vote now in a
little while we'll take a look at your
predictions tonight we've got more
awards great music and of course game
premieres world premieres are a big part
of this show
and you guys have a lot of expectations
on the internet for things there are
lots of rumors lots of leaks
and then sometimes there's surprises
that come out of nowhere enjoy this
[Music]
let's suppose that you were able every
night to dream any dream you wanted to
dream
and that you could have the power within
one night to dream 75 years of time
and you would naturally as you began on
this adventure of dreams fulfill all
your wishes
but now let's um
let's have a surprise
let's have a dream which isn't under
control
and then you would get more and more
adventurous
and you would make further and further
out gambles as to what you would dream
and finally you would dream
where you are now
and now he's the head of xbox please
welcome bill spencer
for 18 years in three generations we've
designed xbox consoles to power your
dreams
we see a future
where you're instantly absorbed in your
games
where worlds are even more like-like
immersive responsive and surprising
where you are at the center of your
gaming experience
next holiday xbox series x will lead us
into the future of console gaming
our fastest most powerful xbox
will set a new bar for performance speed
compatibility
developers
around the globe are already hard at
work building games for xbox series x
our 15 xbox game studios are developing
the largest and most creatively diverse
lineup
of exclusive games in our history
tonight
i'm proud to reveal a project early in
development
from incredibly talented creative team
who are no strangers to the game awards
what you're about to see
was all captured in engine
as being built
to take full advantage of xbox series x
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
mariah
[Music]
all right the fun is just beginning let
me assure you we've got some other great
surprises coming up here at the game
awards now we just ran a poll on twitch
to see who you think is going to be
recognized as the best esports player
and the results are in
the twitch community picked faker
all right that award is coming up next
and nba superstar stephen curry is here
to hand it out we'll see if you guys
called it correctly and still to come in
the show we've got performances by green
day and grimes more amazing music from
the game awards orchestra special
announcements from league of legends
fortnite and apex legends
norman reedus is here
reggie's in the house of course and
we've got a lot more of surprises that
is all coming up but first last year we
started a new initiative with facebook
to spotlight unique stories about the
gaming community around the world this
year we've got three new amazing stories
about global gaming citizens i'm so
proud to have these in the show
and i just can't wait to share them with
you tonight here's our first global
gaming citizen for 2019.
[Applause]
i was born as an afghan refugee
growing up with the fear of am i going
to be able to go to school or not was
always with me
i'm not able to go back to my country
afghanistan is a very traditional
country there is a huge problem here for
women accessing education so i decided
enough is enough and i thought about
coding
code to inspire is the first computer
coding school for girls in afghanistan
we've developed so far more than 20
games our students told me we are very
tired of playing games that the men are
superhero and it's always pretty wide
man so i was like then why you just
don't create your own game
afghan hero girl
when they see the game that they are
playing are made by women
that's an empowerment itself they
understand that they have a voice and
they should be heard
is it possible that the past and future
are colliding
let the new era
begin
[Laughter]
well aren't you just as cute as a button
and aren't you just as creepy as
flattery will get you nowhere deary
rated m for mature
[Music]
um
[Music]
nintendo switch has games lots of games
to play anytime anywhere
[Music]
find the games you want to play your way
on nintendo switch and nintendo switch
leg
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
now please welcome three-time nba
champion and two-time most valuable
player from the golden state warriors
it's stephen curry
what's going on
as uh some of you may know
i had my own gaming related injury
recently
uh i went for that uh that triangle
button
and next thing you know i'm on the floor
and uh
you know
2k is no joke so
once again
esports is the fastest growing sport on
the planet and still breaking records
with
massive multi-million dollar price uh
prize pools and the award for best
esports player recognizes both
outstanding play
regardless of the game
and also good sportsmanship
so here are the nominees
[Applause]
best esports player
champion
[Music]
now
uh and the game award for best esports
player goes to
booga
[Applause]
wow
uh thank you guys so much this is like
the best way to end off my year honestly
um
thank you all to my fans my family my
friends my team sentinels
and most importantly epic games for
making any of this possible and i'm so
glad to be a part of this community and
i can't wait to see what the future
holds thank you guys so much
[Music]
trump
on your feet old blood
not dead
yes
a thousand year war
just to start the apocalypse
beautiful
deadly
right in our way
that's about right
no storm can stop us
oh you noticed that yeah uh playstation
5. all right this show's on fire i'm
here with keith lee the ceo of counter
play and steve gibson the president of
gearbox publishing uh guys uh brand new
announcement brand new ip new game
what is godfall
godfall is a brand new ip set in a brand
new fantasy universe filled with heroic
knights and mysterious magic we call it
a looter slasher all right so looter
slasher tell us a bit about like how is
this going to play
so we're here to reinvent combat for
loot driven action rpgs we'll have third
person real-time melee combat as you
hunt for awesome loot
you can also play the game in solo as
well as in co-op it's going to be fun
for everyone well it looks absolutely
incredible that was all in engine you
know you can see the game that we're
going to get to play there uh steve you
know from gearbox's point of view you
guys nominated tonight obviously
borderlands congrats on that but how do
you guys fit into this picture with sony
and with counter play oh man you know we
love our co-op and our gear at gearbox
so here we are man when and when uh
keith showed us uh godfall
it was so amazing to us we had to call
our friends over at sony our friends
over at epic say hey help us make this
work on your technology and hardware
keith we're gonna do everything we can
for you man and we're excited we're so
excited announced this is gonna be a now
this is launched exclusively on the
playstation 5 and epic game store this
holiday all right holiday 2020 holiday
24 we're gonna get all right playstation
five games what's going on all right
this is amazing well guys
congratulations it looks absolutely
incredible i'm sure we'll see more next
year right you sure will awesome all
right congrats on the announcement
awesome guys all right well we'd like to
welcome some uh we'd like to recognize
some other of our winners tonight uh so
in the category of best audio design for
best in-game audio and sound design
those nominees are
call of duty modern warfare
control death stranding
here's five
resident evil two
okay fan favorite and securo shadows
died twice
and the game award goes to
call of duty modern warfare
congratulations to the guys at infinity
ward all right
for best strategy game focused on
real-time or turn-based strategy those
nominees are age of wonders planet fall
anno 1800 fire emblem three houses
total war three kingdoms tropico six and
war group
and the game award in that category goes
to
fire emblem three houses
all right in the category of content
creator of the year for a streamer or
content creator who made an important
positive impact on the industry this
year the nominees are
courage who's in the house here
dr lupo
ewok
graf
and shroud
and the game award goes to
shroud
congratulations
all right well we've had some great
world premieres and announcements to
start off the show and we've talked
about xbox we've talked about
playstation
another platform we probably should talk
about now we have another world premiere
brand new game announcement
that uh
i don't think you guys are expecting but
we're really excited to share with you
here on the game awards check this out
[Music]
it is time to choose
accept your fate and await oblivion
[Music]
or make a stand
and fight for survival
step into the light young hero
be brave
[Music]
[Music]
all right right now i'm joined by my
fellow canadian rebecca ford live
operations and community director at
digital extremes
is that for canada for rebecca for both
of them all right rebecca welcome to the
game awards you've been up here before
um
warframe uh tell us what's the latest on
warframe you know we've been making this
game for seven years and each year we
update it with the space ninja flare but
uh we think it's time to go space pirate
and this whole empyrion thing is what
our community wants to know about yes i
know you guys have teased that um what
can you tell us about it when's it gonna
come out well we were thinking uh on pc
we would launch it right now oh okay
here we go
live right now all right that's
fantastic and uh people will be able to
get their hands on it tonight anything
else that we should be uh keeping in
mind yeah our playstation 4 and xbox one
tenno have the rising tide update which
means they are now preparing for
imperial nintendo switch will come soon
and it's really just uh if you've been
following warframe story there's a lot
to find in this update so
why not launch it on pc okay so it's uh
out right now on pc and we'll take a
look at it okay check it out well thanks
rebecca let's take a look
warframe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tonight we're happy to welcome samsung
as a new partner of the game awards and
throughout the night you'll be hearing
from my fellow canadian lots of
canadians tonight linus tech tips about
samsung's qled tvs which are optimized
for the best gaming experience take a
look
i'm linus from linus tech tips and i'll
be talking about some of the ways living
room gaming is better than ever when i
was a kid my first gaming tv was about
this big and it had a vhs player built
into it not very immersive with a
samsung qled tv not only can you see
more than ever before but at 4k
resolution with sizes of up to 82 inches
the image clarity is unbelievable and
with samsung's 10-year burn-in guarantee
you can game without worry
my name is soleil many people know me as
ewok i am deaf and i play fortnite and
i'm 14.
i was just a streamer with a very small
following
in the past 14 months everything's
really taken off and it's been
absolutely incredible
i mean i've become the first woman in
phase clan
my goal is to see many more females
playing and considered at an equal level
and i really want to see that explode in
the gaming world i think that would be
really nice
[Applause]
and ewok's here with us tonight we're so
glad to have her with us all right uh
here with me now is daniel ketchum he's
the senior art director for magic the
gathering dan welcome to the game awards
thank you happy to be here you're on
brand what's uh what's next uh well jeff
i'm excited to tell you that in january
magic we will be returning to one of our
most beloved worlds uh so the last time
we went to tharos a world of gods myths
and monsters we saw our hero else beth
tyrell my favorite planeswalker
betrayed by the gods and banished to
walk the underworld but now our hero is
ready to defy death and escape her fate
and i'm here to give you a sneak peek at
what's in store for her uh now with
music by rameen jawedy this is the
trailer for theros beyond death all
right check it out thanks so much
[Applause]
see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right the new game announcements
just keep rolling here at the game words
eventually we'll get some games you
already know about but let's keep going
with things you haven't seen before
here's another world premiere
[Music]
uh
[Music]
now she's a creative director and the
lead art designer from the evil within
series please welcome ikumi nakamura
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
um please be a bear
with my english
okay
good art can't change over time
but great art stays great
great at stay
great facts a great art sparks joy in
our brains and helps us to change the
way we think
because sometimes we we need to change
it to survive
this year i had a big change in my life
and it's been a crazy year
[Laughter]
but i'm alive
was it a crazy year for you
[Applause]
you are not alone because i'm here
and we have great games with great art
here are the nominees for best art
election
our
middle east
best art direction presented by samsung
qled
[Applause]
so
[Music]
yeah
and as you know
i am a fortune teller
i can see
and
and
the winner is
controller
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
this is incredible trying to uh avoid
any explicit language right now
um
i think the big thank you goes to the
art director janna bulkin
he is an amazing person he's worked that
remedy for a long while
and he had this crystal clear vision of
what he wanted to achieve with control
and he did amazing things together with
his team i also have to thank stewart
mcdonald who is the world design
director now anti-bombing handle the
characters and all the creepy monsters
that existed in this game
and i can't imagine
a better group of artists and talented
creative people to work with and this is
thanks to you guys
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
all right congratulations to the guys at
uh remedy we've got lots more words
coming up but right now i'm here with
donald mustard worldwide creative
director for epic games donald welcome
back to the game it's a yearly thing i
feel like we always get to hang out it's
fun this is great well you guys have
built uh quite a franchise in fortnite
and uh the last couple years have just
been been so crazy for you guys but what
i love is that you're you're constantly
innovating with this game that's what
we're trying to no it's uh you know we i
think we're all just trying to make
stuff that we think is fun that we think
is cool and uh you never quite expect
something to
uh take off the way that fortnite did
right but but once that momentum
happened we're just like man how do we
just let's gotta lean in and how do we
find ways to
really just
push the idea of what a persistent
virtual place can be and so that's why
even this year martial
the concert yeah we start the year off
with a concert that has you know
over 10 million people in it you know we
we roll into you know huge monster
fights and we've got uh you know the
thing we've been planning forever to
like how do we find a way to
suck the entire world into the zero
point black hole and turn the game off
and and like all this stuff but that all
in some ways i think pales in comparison
to what's about to happen this weekend
uh yeah something pretty cool is gonna
happen in a few hours you know and on
saturday on saturday you guys probably
have seen uh teasing a little bit about
something that's happening at risky
reels um
tied to star wars yeah
skywalker right yes yes and it's
pretty cool what can you tell us about
it
you know i probably can't tell you much
but
i have a friend who can okay let's take
a look
thanks donald uh hey everyone it's jj
abrams director of the rise of skywalker
uh join me in fortnight on saturday for
an exclusive look at the movie uh to see
the whole thing you gotta be in the game
so i'll see you in fortnight on saturday
[Music]
thanks yeah uh
this is so cool uh and i think you know
some people online is like oh you're
just running a clip or whatever and i
don't know how much you want to reveal
but you and i have been talking all year
about you know building a live
experience around this i'm excited i'm
gonna get to actually be in the game as
well kind of interacting with with with
jj and i don't know how much you want to
tell us about it but it's it's going to
be a
live participatory experience right i
think it's going to be like something
that no one's ever seen before ever i
mean jj and jeff we're going to be live
yes
oh that's and that's that's the glider
we're going to get i think there's also
to be that exactly wait so hold on
that's like star wars
so you never know there's an attack
happening everyone who shows up like as
you drop out of the battle bus you're
all going to pop those out like everyone
that shows up is going to get tie
whispers it's awesome you're flying
around and uh jj and jeff will be there
live
in the game and
we're going to see this awesome clip
from star wars it's a it's brief but
i've seen it many times it's very very
good you want to see it um and then some
other crazy stuff is going to happen and
you should come yeah no i i'm really
excited about sort of what this means i
think for sort of programming inside of
games
shared experiences like the game awards
people all coming together watching this
but this is inside the game world i'm
really excited about what is going to
happen on saturday so right from the
game awards to that um but before then i
know you've got some other um some some
cool things that people can pick up in
fortnite we do so there's one more thing
so right now uh you can go to fortnite
and these are now available in the game
they're some of my favorite characters
of all time ray and finn and the awesome
new sith trooper and they're in the game
right now you can go get it get loaded
up for saturday
amazing well i gotta say uh we are
really excited about what you guys have
you know put together with you lucas and
disney um to have this come together
this weekend i know these things are
never easy to pull off but uh yeah i'm
really excited about what it's gonna
could be so saturday saturday 2 p.m
eastern and it's live like we're doing
it live and it's going to be amazing and
crazy just like this i was gonna say
we'll be there and it'll probably be tie
fighters there'll be other crazy things
going on donald uh thanks as always for
coming by the game awards uh good luck i
know you guys are up for a bunch of
awards tonight as well um and we've got
much more uh game awards coming up trump
is everybody
all right well we've got a lot of brand
new game announcements tonight um and
this next one comes from a team up in my
home country of canada i keep mentioning
canada but this is uh a game that uh i
think you'll be surprised by and i saw
it i said hey this would be a cool thing
to announce at the game awards so check
it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sons of the forest we got some cool
stuff tonight all right well one of the
most played games in the world is league
of legends and tonight
we're happy to have riot and its new
riot forge division with us to reveal
their first single player experience for
the franchise
take a look at
[Applause]
[Music]
this my kin
long have you waited
now
the time has come
for your revenge
[Applause]
across
[Music]
suffering
[Music]
they will know your name
ruined king airship syndicate i'm here
with joe madd joe uh you guys have made
some amazing games over the years uh
first of all congratulations on working
with riot the reveal you guys making the
first game what it is um tell us more
about what we just saw on that teaser
yeah so i'm so excited we can finally
talk about this i was sure i would leak
it before now but uh we are doing the
first ever uh riot forge game
uh and as you saw it is uh the ruin king
a league of legends story
we're basically building on our
experience making battle chasers and
dark siders to create a
story driven turn-based rpg we have a
new take on on turn-based combat that's
really cool
obviously the visual
the art and visuals that our studio is
known for
and the story takes place
after burning tides
so everyone believes gangplank is dead
bilgewater is in chaos and you'll
actually play as some league champions
and explore bilgewater
the shadow isles and we have a lot of
other surprises as well and poros
they're mandatory apparently all right
well it sounds like this is something
you've been working on for a little
while too right
uh we have we have yes and i can't say
anymore okay that's all you're allowed
to say all right well it's so exciting
to have riot with us here at the game
awards for the first time joe you
guys the games so far amazing and it's
just an honor to be here awesome well
thanks so much for announcing with us it
means the world to us and i know all the
league of legends fans around the entire
world who are tuned in tonight so joe
can i can't wait i can't wait to hear
what you guys think you'll be on these
social medias right i will i'm going
right now thank you very much joe mack
thank you great announcement league of
legends fantastic
when we come back a performance by
grimes the award for best action game
with norman reedus and a special
announcement from an apex legend still
to come ninja presents best multiplayer
game and an extended look at ghost of
tsushima
this is the game awards don't go
anywhere
[Music]
ladies and gents
watch out because tonight the birds
afraid are hijacking
the game awards
you have got to be kidding me
courage i said no come on harley we've
been here training for weeks don't take
this the wrong way or nothing but you
guys just aren't really birds of prey
material no offense what i love you
of course you do snookums now quit
messing around let's give these people
what they want
ladies if you want boys to respect you
you have to show them that you're
serious
blow something up
[Music]
hit someone
nothing gets a guy's attention like
violence
oh i love this chick she's got rages i
don't have razor shoes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all the wickedness that mankind can
produce
we heard you may want to quit vaping but
we can't help you we can barely hold
these protest signs but we can tell you
about this is quitting an easy text to
quit service it's the least and most we
can do
mummy is dead hugo you'll never see her
again you go down
keep running forever you are a monster
[Music]
[Music]
be sure
to stay
in the light
nominees for 2019 gaming tweet of the
year
[Music]
stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the game awards all
right music is a big part of games and
cyberpunk 2077 is one of the most
anticipated games coming out next year
well hello to everyone at cd projekt red
they're over in poland and working hard
to finish the game but right now we've
got a behind-the-scenes look at the
soundtrack to cyberpunk 2077 check it
out
[Applause]
even in the dystopian future hard rap
lives on we want to provide you with the
soundtrack to [ __ ] [ __ ] up
i mean we're not here as refused we're
here samurai it's a very interesting
thing to be part of we really work on
these songs trying to make them as good
as possible i think my music fits with
my city because both are scary and
pretty at the same time
my music will be featured in cyberpunk
2077 i'm super excited
it's quite rebellious and it's quite
noisy and aggressive i think industrial
is the word
i can't wait to see how the two worlds
actually meet i mean it's been a lot of
fun playing these beats it's very punk
rock in the way in its approach you're
building these systems to make really
rugged rough edgy music psychedelic
creepy yet uplifting and engaging
and you can see a lot of kind of
industrial stuff and revolution
happening sort of mixing punk music and
like what electronic music could be in
the future so we have some tracks that
are super dirty super heavy and then we
have some tracks that are very beautiful
and ambient
that was just a glimpse of what we have
in store for you see you in night city
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now he's the star of the walking
dead and a best performance nominee
tonight for his role as sam porter
bridges in death stranding
here's norman reedus
hello
what's up
hi
all right it's time to present the award
for best action game
these games are all widely wildly
different some new franchises some
beloved sequels all with their own
unique adversaries and objectives
but the one thing that they have in
common is that they set the bar for
lively combat and thrills
all right ready
all right all right
all right here's the nominees
best action game
try and keep up
to kick some
[Applause]
it's the strongest
all right
this is heavy and the winner is
devil may cry 5.
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
thank you so much for all the fans who
have been supporting us and thank you so
much for waiting 11 years for uh
[Applause]
i was really happy to stick with my
roots and uh
trying to make as pure of an action game
as possible
he's back
thank you
[Applause]
congrats to the dmc guys all right i'm
now joined by jeff adam the studio lead
and founder of two games from
canada i don't know how it all works out
that way but a lot of cat grimes
canadian jeff all right anyways uh tell
us what you're working on up at toque
thanks jeff i'm super excited to be here
with the world premiere of the game
we've been working on up in montreal
salute
um when we started working on this game
we we had the idea to put action back in
action rpg and what better place than in
dungeons and dragons
forgotten realms ice wind dale
slay together with your friends i'm
super pleased to announce dungeons and
dragons dark alliance let's check it out
[Music]
come on
[Music]
my god
my god
all right up next is the award for the
absolute best
it's the most
wonderful time
of the year
wow i was a little pitchy on that one i
should keep practicing
looks like it's mirage everybody what's
up mirage hey keely my man what's going
on well we're kind of in the middle of
the game awards right now but uh yep
what's going on with you man oh is that
tonight tell me tell me did i already
win for best all-around competitor in a
battle royale based on skills but mostly
good looks
that is such a specific award and as i
told you on twitter it does not exist
i'm sorry
oh okay okay i see what you're doing
keeping the mystery alive for the
audience i get it it's a secret award i
get later
wink it's not like i haven't been
practicing my acceptance speech
wow these things are really heavy
i'd like to thank my mother for my
exceptional good looks
mirage we have a show we've got lots of
announcements to get to uh is there a
purpose of today's call oh right well i
know everybody's always asking for more
mirage content because uh obviously and
i think i speak for everyone when i say
we've all had enough of crypto so kelly
i'm here tonight to just give the people
what they want and keely keeley check
this out this is so cool watch
i'm a captain
the captain of what exactly the mirage
voyage oh yeah it's my big hollow day
bash you get it hollow days because the
oh and i do holler grams
anyway can i put you down for a plus one
fine uh when does it start mirage
oh that's the best part this party wait
for it starts right
now
oh hey and i've got presents for
everyone at the awards and all you
beautiful people watching at home join
me at the party and you all get this
free
exclusive legendary skin of my matching
g7 sexy huh
and the gun doesn't look bad either
yeah extremely generous of you mirage
thank you for that what can i say jeff i
am a giver
all right well uh listen up we do have a
show to uh to to you know get back to so
thanks mirage okay okay best buddy can't
wait to see you and everybody else at
the biggest celebration in the outlands
it's party time
[Music]
you'll warm up in the respawn chamber
i'm quicker than you think
i enjoy the winter
months for the winter
opening fire
you know you missed me
ah you're a bit too slow my brother
[Music]
let's ride the train
[Music]
train let's do this
[Music]
target spotted
we are awesome
watson watching get in here with me
let's take an elfie
no
why are you looking me that way
up next dr bunsen honeydew and beaker
present games for impact plus reggie is
here and he's ready and later a brand
new look at ghost of tsushima it's all
coming up on the game awards
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's
[Music]
this
is somebody
[Music]
there you go apple arcade at the game
awards for the first time ultimate
rivals right we have so much more show
coming up uh we've got green day coming
up but right now we've got a world
premiere from xbox and moon studios
here's a brand new look at ori the will
of west
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
play it with xbox game pass
my favorite thing about being a game
designer is i didn't have to pick one
subject to specialize in
you know
i'm able to just follow my interests
and spend lots of time studying you know
galactic evolution or urban planning
or psychology whatever it is
and then i just kind of turn that into a
toy into a game part of my job is just
enjoying exploring the world and letting
my interest take me wherever they go and
there are not too many jobs i think let
you do that
when it comes to upping your competition
level there's no doubt that more frames
per second makes a measurable difference
trust me that's why samsung's latest
qled tvs feature native support for
games running it up to 120 frames per
second with very low input lag and this
sweet auto game mode that detects when
you're gaming and turns off any extra
image processing they've even got amd
freesync for smoother animations when
the frame rate dips
[Music]
the war had just started when i arrived
to iraq we did our thing
we had some experiences and when we came
back when we got off that plane
before we can even embrace our loved
ones
our fire team leader says do not tell
anybody what happened to you
or what you saw or what you experienced
that starts
the stigma
of mental health
stack up is a military charity
supporting u.s and allied veterans
mental health through gaming
overwatch is our newest program and it
is simply having a chat client up
somebody comes in and says they need to
talk or they're interested to get into a
game we have somebody available for them
they may not want to come out there and
see a counselor for an hour you know
once a week but they may come out there
and play a video game and start talking
about their experiences of war or the
struggles that they're having right now
it has become my passion to end the
stigma of mental health
[Applause]
please welcome two of the most
innovative visionaries in the history of
gaming and just about everything else
from muppet labs dr bunsen honeydew and
beaker
oh thank you thank you thank you
greetings fellow gaming enthusiasts it's
great to be here at the game awards i am
dr bunsen honeydew and this is my
assistant beaker
beekee
where did you go
oh um
i guess he's stuck in the lobby
nothing well well
in just a few moments we will reveal the
winner of games for impact but first i
was hoping to oh oh here's biki now
oh good to see you
[Applause]
i'm so glad you're here wearing vr
goggles to demonstrate our brand new
game mimi
yes
as you can see beaker is wearing muppet
labs proprietary next generation
technology vr super gluey goggles
you can put them on but you can't get
them off let me remember
and now we will premiere the exciting
new muppet labs game
oh oh beaker uh beaker i i forgot i
forgot the what are we calling it
of course the untitled beaker game
excellent choice let the game begin
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
oh well
um here are the nominees for games for
impact recognizing socially conscious
and progressive games in the industry
roll the nominees
games for impact
you want me to paint this whole town
[Music]
we have a lot of people looking for your
brother and why is it so dark
[Music]
here we go
and the winner is
what are you doing outside the game
you just plea hey hey give that back to
me peter get him get him
oh oh no that's me that's me beaker
where did he go where did he go no no no
where is he oh get
there okay
you've got him under control
all right okay okay
thank you beaker
would you please
hold him with hold his big shot
hold his beaker that's it get him get
him good
sorry about that folks
the award for games
would you
have you got it
[Music]
goose
stop it
stop it
all right
the award for games for impact goes to
no not geese
greece
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wonderful congratulations thank you to
the muppets
well we want to
share this award with first of all
conrad or creative director with all the
team back at home we made a really good
team and we could have never made it
without them we have to thank devolver
for allowing us to do the game we wanted
to make
and something yes well first of all i
mean i would like to thank especially to
all those people that share their
stories with us they send really really
moving stories while they were playing
greece that's something that obviously
when you create a game you try to do
these kind of things but you never know
you're gonna get to someone and we
pretty much are so moved when you're
when we receive this story so please
keep sharing it with us because it's
amazing and thank you everybody that
play and support greece thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
all right sorry thanks to bunsen and
beaker lifelong dream to have them here
at the show all right uh
i also want to mention something called
the game festival i know if you heard
about that online but we're launching a
new thing tied to the game awards called
the game festival and the vision for
that is to give all of you around the
world who watch the show you watch
trailers you love games a chance to play
a bunch of games and this year we're
partnering with steam and if you head to
steam for the next 48 hours a little bit
less than that since it started this
morning we have first look demos of over
a dozen upcoming games that you can play
for free on steam and i think that's
kind of the future where this all goes
is not necessarily these local events
where you have to travel somewhere to
play a game but actually bringing games
into your homes and and the places you
work and live
to play so play all those games the game
festival uh concludes saturday at 10 a.m
pacific and next year we're gonna do it
across all the platforms and it's gonna
be a big thing so we're looking forward
to doing more with that um all right
well now we're gonna present some more
awards uh and let's get into the best
family game the nominees for that
category are luigi's mansion 3.
ring fit adventure
super mario maker 2
super smash brothers ultimate
and yoshi's crafted world
kind of like nintendo's chances in this
category um and the game award goes to
luigi's mansion three
congratulations
all right category of best sports racing
game for the best traditional and
non-traditional sports racing game and
those nominees are
crash team racing nitro fueled
announced last year at the game awards
dirt rally 2.0 e football pro evolution
soccer 2020 f1 2019 and fifa 20.
and the game award goes to
crash team racing nitro fuel
okay
and for the best mobile game the
nominees are
call of duty mobile grindstone sayonara
wild hearts which we announced last year
sky children of the light and what the
golf
and the game award in that category goes
to
call of duty mobile congratulations guys
all right well now i'd like to welcome
the co-creators of dishonored and pray
raph and julian are here you may have
seen online that they just announced
their brand new studio wolf ian said
here at the game awards they were going
to reveal their first game so guys
welcome to the game awards you've been
here before but you've got this new
studio so tell me a bit about uh wolfi
what's different about it so well we
took a long break but uh it looks like
we can't stay away from making them for
very long so we're just back at it now
with world five
yeah well what can you tell us about the
game we know the studio we don't know
anything about the game but that's gonna
change now right yeah so um you've
mentioned dishonored and pray as some of
our past games uh we have passion for
interesting worlds to explore uh we have
passion for depth of interactivity
and of course we have passion for
simulation in general so this new game
has all of these values but this time we
have a bit of a different approach
we brought a
glimpse to show you and through a teaser
and we're very excited it's amazing one
of my favorite premieres in the show
tonight it looks incredible you're going
to see the real game here guys uh we
can't wait to hear more about this let's
take a look at the first look at the
first project from wolfie enjoy thank
you
[Music]
the west
the land of opportunity
a place where you can be a hero
scoundrel
and anything in between
this ain't quite the wild west as you
know it
there are ancient powers at war with
each other
strange entities lurking in the dead of
night with their own rules in their own
peculiar motives
welcome to the weird west
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
coming out here could be the best thing
that ever happened to you
if you can survive
that is
wild west all right up next a brand new
mmo action rpg game from a legendary
franchise check out this announcement
[Music]
uh
[Music]
it's us
[Music]
i
[Applause]
coming up the first look at a brand new
game from an exciting new studio and
ninja is here to hand out the award for
best multiplayer game
and still to come
more premieres more awards an extended
preview from ghost of tsushima and green
day performs live
the game awards will be right back
[Applause]
hi i'm looking for stadia
what what stadia
stadia is only the newest most logic
defined mind-bending absurd gaming
platform on earth forget boxes forget
consoles just your games your screens
and electric air and this electric air
is
stadium
unlike consoles stadia doesn't take up
any space
it makes no noise it has no smell watch
go find stadia boy
don't worry
you'll never find it okay you can play
stadia with this cydia likes to party
okay 60 fps
[Music]
with stadium you can go virtually
anywhere
live anywhere this is amazing play with
any who so we're inside a game i think i
met a guy gary stadia is gaming for free
range humans sorry stadia travels across
screens
no downloads no updates no waiting
stadia bends time and space to take you
straight to your game so stadia is the
best
technically this is stadium stadium
streaming pipeline leverages decades of
google research is that a dog
[Music]
is so impossibly mind-bending so free to
move from screen to screen still not
depending on downloads or updates it's
like nothing
nothing you've ever played draw before
[Music]
unthink the things you think are things
free your mind at the one place for all
the ways we play stadium
wow you guys maybe have stadia
[Music]
[Applause]
when pubg mobile one of the biggest
video games in the world and global
green a world-renowned non-profit
partnered to help save the amazon we
challenged people across the globe to
stand together and fight to protect our
planet we've already lost 20 percent of
the amazon due to fires and
deforestation and the amazon is critical
to protecting us from the devastating
effects of climate change thanks to pubg
mobile and their commitment to harness
the power of gaming for good and thanks
to all of you we are starting to make a
real difference global greens local
partners on the ground can now help put
out some of the fires and plant
thousands of new trees in the amazon
but this isn't the end
it's just the beginning the next
generation is depending on us
go to globalgreen.org
forward slash fight for the amazon and
donate to continue the fight
fight for the amazon
nintendo switch has fights to win
and scores to set up
[Music]
find your battle nintendo switch and
nintendo switch
[Music]
light rise and shine it's magic time
now it's time for you to welcome the
challenge
play magic together in the wheel
download free
what's up guys i'm bajira and on my
stream i'm all about helping my viewers
accomplish their goals whether it's
making progress in gaming fitness or
just taking control of their health in
general and if one of your goals is to
quit vaping truth is a program that can
help it's called this is quitting it's
free anonymous text based available any
time of day right on your phone and it's
already helping thousands of people quit
all you have to do is text ditch jewel
to 88709 to join the program because you
can quit but you don't do it alone visit
thetruth.com for more information and
enjoy the game awards
[Music]
all right now here's a brand new game
announcement from oculus studios check
it out
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
he's one of the most watched streamers
alive and the winner of last year's game
award for content creator of the year
please welcome ninja
[Applause]
hello everyone
thank you guys so much for obviously
being here i've been playing video games
my entire life
and there's something magical about a
solo player experience
and the only way to enhance that
is to play games with your friends
i've literally defined my entire career
by playing online multiplayer games
and here are the nominees for the best
multiplayer game of the year
best multiplayer game
[Music]
some amazing games let's be real all
right
the game award for best multiplayer game
goes to
it's a lot more difficult to open up
than you think
uh apex legends
[Applause]
[Music]
wow thank you so much the last four
years has been transformative for
respawn this year has been crazy for us
so for all the team that stuck around
and believed and made this magic happen
thank you to the fans thank you so much
i'd just like to thank the team at
respawn of crazy passionate super
talented individuals for going with us
on this crazy journey we changed our
genre we changed our business model we
made our first character based game and
we changed ips while we were shipping a
triple a shooter so thank you i love you
guys
[Applause]
all right well uh congratulations to
respawn uh great to see apex uh winning
best multiplayer game now this year tick
tock has swept the nation with its
hashtag challenges for the past few
weeks fans have been celebrating gaming
on tick tock with over 450 million video
views so far uh tonight you can use the
hashtag on tick tock to join the
celebration of gaming and esports
biggest night in the contest uh cheesy
c64 he's the guy that uh won it right
there so uh congratulations to him all
right um we've got so much more game
awards coming up uh the gaming on tick
tock contest will continue for the next
few days cheesy c64 the next twitch poll
is open for best ongoing game you can go
vote now and we'll see who you think is
going to take home the game award in
just a bit but right now let's talk
about a big playstation 4 title that's
coming next year from the guys at sucker
punch
ghost of tashima you probably saw this
teased earlier this week i am so excited
about this game and what sucker punch is
bringing to life we have our longest
world premiere in the show tonight as
i've been saying a true cinematic look
enjoy
at ghost of tashima
trump
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
samurai
oh
[Music]
the ghost
some say
he died on the beach
others
say he is a storm made flesh
[Music]
when the wind thrashes their tents and
bulls
they know he is coming
[Music]
[Music]
chill
tell him i'm coming
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
cause i can't
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
girl's dancing
the game awards orchestra let's give it
up for our incredible conductor tonight
max rouge the game awards orchestra
they'll be back later for an incredible
montage celebrating our game of the year
nominees and game of the year will be
presented by some very special guests
surprise guests so stay tuned for that
but right now we've got another world
premiere a look at gears tactics check
it out
[Applause]
[Music]
they came for us
he invaded every part of our world
so we did the only thing we could
we set the world on fire
now my war begins
against the monster that created these
monsters
and it's time to go hunting
don't go gentle
bring it [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
come see what my newest creation
thinks of yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i won't get to get what i'm after
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's turn back to twitch we
asked uh twitch to predict the winner
for the best ongoing game category and
they chose final fantasy 14. we will
find out when we present that award a
little bit just who wins all right we've
also got more game announcements still
to go on the way a performance that's
going to rock the house by green day
the award for best game direction and of
course game of the year
right now here's a world premiere of a
brand new game from a team in china it's
a multiplayer melee combat game that
you're seeing for the first time here is
naraka bladepoint
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to magic school
now that we've covered flying let's talk
about giant angels
not to be confused with bird people
bird people are their own thing
play magic for gathering
download free
how many years have i waited for this
moment
for the one that stood alone against the
storm
for the one they called
the warrior
of light
[Music]
this tragedy
greater even the seventh humble calamity
must be undone
if history must be unwritten
let it be unwritten
[Music]
become what we must
become
the warrior of darkness
[Music]
oh my name is luke and i'm 11 years old
my game is called let's be wall and it's
made with the roblox studio game engine
it starts off all gray this guy it says
he's depressed
as he plays the obstacle course he
learns about the depression so this is
to get people talking so they don't
bottle their feelings up
i was pregnant with our youngest son
and my late husband got very very sick
the doctors called it a major depressive
episode his mental illness overtook him
by way of suicide and so we lost him
when luke was two years old at the time
[Music]
it's kind of hard to explain like how my
dad died when i was very young i just
wanted to spread a positive message that
is okay to talk about mental illness i
hope i've helped people
[Music]
now she's a host and producer for ign
please welcome sydney goodman
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm here to present the award for best
ongoing game recognizing that we keep
playing our favorite games year after
year and acknowledging the teams that
keep these massively popular franchises
fresh with new content
more experiences and evolving ways to
play
here are the nominees
best ongoing game
[Music]
so
and the game award for best ongoing game
goes to
fortnite
[Applause]
wow this is amazing thank you uh
so like last year uh we represent just
like the teeniest portion of the
now over a thousand people who
work to make fortnite something that is
incredible
every single day
and you know we're just
so humbled
uh constantly
to have the opportunity to even make
something
like fortnite um it's incredible
i think that uh
you know as i was saying earlier right
like this idea that we need to lean into
what a persistent virtual place can be
and the more that we're trying to
experiment with stuff and try different
things um we're we're finding more and
more that our goal is to try to create a
metaverse to create a place right where
where all ip can live together where all
kinds of experiences can happen where we
can create a thing that is totally new a
totally new emergent type of
media really
and uh
we are so inspired by everything you're
doing i'm just blown away by what we see
here tonight it's it's uh it's truly
astounding and incredible uh
thank you for all the work you do
thank you for all the people who play
fortnite for who come up to all of us
all the time and give us your incredible
ideas and your feedback and we just
can't wait to keep making more um
i'd be remiss if i didn't take one
little personal note to thank my wife my
daughter my family my party people
uh we love you thank you so much
see you guys saturday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
from the developers who worked on max
payne
quantum break
armor 3
world of tanks and
trivial pursuit mobile
[Music]
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
client called intel is located okay
thanks jane
but the competition is sending their
team
as expected let's get this job done
there you go that's nine to five and i'm
here with red hill games ceo mattias
matteis great to have you with us uh
what is nine to five what can we expect
thank you jeff glad to be here nine to
five is a new first person tactical
shooter it's set in a world where
corporations rule everything and being a
mercenary is just another job now a lot
of modern shooters can be a little bit
chaotic and that's kind of what makes
905 special we really put a lot of focus
on the strategic gameplay of the team
and playing together and you know making
your changes and your tactics from round
to round and obviously all that triumphs
over brute force at the end all right
well when can we expect to hear more
next year or so 2020 uh we're launching
the alpha but you can actually sign up
today at nine to five dot game so go
ahead enjoy and download all right a
little bit of a tease nine to five all
right thanks very much for being here so
fast appreciate it all right we're gonna
hand out some more awards right now
in the category of esports game of the
year the nominees are counter-strike
global offensive dota 2
fortnite
league of legends and overwatch
and the game award goes to
league of legends congratulations to
ryan
for the best vr ar game those nominees
are asgard's wrath
blood and truth
beat saber
no man's sky
and trover saves the universe
and the game award goes to
beat saber congratulations to beat games
for the award for best performance
awarded to an individual for voice over
acting motion and or performance capture
the nominees are ashley birch for the
outer worlds
courtney hope for control
laura bailey for gears five
mads mikkelsen for death stranding
matthew peretta for control
and norman reedus for death stranding
and the game award goes to
mads mikkelsen for death stranding
congratulations mads
this year we also added a fan category
over the past few days called players
voice and a lot of you around the world
voted tournament style to pick your
favorite game this was 100 in control of
the fans and the winner of the fan vote
is
fire emblem three houses congratulations
all right well throughout the show
you've heard three incredible stories
about our global gaming citizens and
we're so honored to have them here with
us tonight please join me in recognizing
this year's class of global gaming
citizens
[Applause]
congratulations guys
[Applause]
beautiful
a selfie all right uh we're so proud of
that program we intend to continue that
year after year i love telling all these
stories of amazing people around the
world who uh i think represent gaming at
its best all right up next we've got
music from green day reggie's in the
house to present
our indie game award we've got more
world premieres more game awards
orchestra and the big award game of the
year presented by some special guests
now the popular action mmorpg black
desert has only been available for pc
and console but now black desert mobile
is available on ios and android you can
download it tonight and get a true
mmorpg at your fingertips check it out
[Music]
[Music]
a monster
[Music]
be sure
to stay
in the light
let's say you're not the super
competitive type and you're more about
that eye candy a samsung qled tv has got
you covered there too when it comes to
the most eye-popping visuals hdr is
where it's at quantum dot technology
delivers amazing color fidelity while
full array local dimming allows the
brightest and darkest parts of the scene
to look their best features like these
are why samsung qled tv was a best of
innovation honoree for gaming at ces
2019 and they're nominated again for
2020 so keep a lookout
[Music]
i didn't think anybody was really going
to play this game
we got
over a half a million letters written in
the first couple months which just
we were not prepared for
kind words is a game about writing nice
letters to people all real people
anonymously online sharing their worries
and making each other feel better
pushing the definition of games is
something that i really get excited
about
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wd black
fine-tuned for performance purpose built
for gamer to play without limits
storage solutions with the capacity
speed and reliability to win
wd black
drive your game
[Music]
we are excited to welcome wd black to
the game awards as the official storage
sponsor all of tonight's world premieres
have been safely stored on wd black and
get command performance with ssd speed
check out wdblack.com for a chance to
win a decked out gaming rig and wd black
products all right now i'm very excited
to introduce our next performance
one of my passions outside of gaming is
live music whenever i go to a show i'm
always thinking about who would be
perfect here for the game awards
and this band has been on my list since
the beginning they've won five grammys
they're members of the rock and roll
hall of fame they've sold over 85
million albums worldwide
they've got their own video game
announcement as you're about to find out
get on your feet ladies and gentlemen
this is green day
[Applause]
[Music]
own
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to
[Music]
[Music]
i'm is here
[Music]
[Music]
oh
welcome to paradise
get your [ __ ] hands up in the air
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to
[Music]
it's all right we can come down here and
dance if you want to
come on man this is gaming it's supposed
to be free free love come on let's come
on come on out
i dare you
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hurry up cause i'm making no fungus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
under the pressure
[Music]
up in the end
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
correct
how about that green day everybody
the worlds of virtual reality and rock
just collided like never before beat
saber and green day the collab we've
always wanted and you don't have to wait
long the music pack drops tonight on all
platforms soon you'll be able to play
six of the band's iconic hits and brand
new singles from the album father of all
which is out on february 7th thank you
so much to green day for playing the
game awards uh we have a lot of shows
still coming up of course we've got the
award for best game direction we've got
game of the year and yes we've still got
some announcements and surprises for you
guys
at gaming's biggest night it just gets
bigger and bigger running all around the
world uh and we've got another world
premiere for you to check out right now
enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
it is an eternal island of legend
a place of unimaginable beauty
and a growing evil
where the forces of death and life
are in constant conflict
for centuries
many have come in search of its power
only to fall to its corruption
[Applause]
[Applause]
and now
you have come to this place
lured by the promise of power and
immortality
the darkness
that's new world and i was just down at
irvine at the studio visiting the devs a
couple of months ago had a great time
playing it and it looks really cool and
you can get more info at newworld.com
uh all right well now please welcome to
the stage a good friend of the game
awards he's been here every year since
the first show with a perfect attendance
record of course he's the former
president of nintendo of america a
friend to all of us you can follow matt
twitter at reggie give it up for reggie
fizza day
fisa mek is in the house
thank you thank you thank you for that
warm welcome
it was just over 16 years ago that i
joined this industry as an executive
but truth be told
i've been around as a fan and as a
player for so much longer
like you i've witnessed the growth of
our favorite form of entertainment
and now video games are bigger than the
movie industry
bigger than music
[Music]
bigger than television
but most importantly
video games continue to innovate
not only as entertainment
but also into areas far more profound
experiences with their foundation in
video game technology
are being used to help surgeons practice
before a difficult procedure
and to enable college students to
simulate business situations and develop
real world skills
i may no longer be an executive in this
industry
but i'll always be an ambassador for
video games
as a force for good
and a force for fun
in this category
fresh indie game
you can see how games are continuing to
evolve
as entertainment
i think this is the most important award
of the night
because i believe indie developers are
the most important creators in this
industry
[Applause]
why
because every nominee this year
and every year at one time
was an indie developer
in the same sense that everyone was once
a kid sketching a superhero in the
middle of class
or lying in bed at night thinking of
worlds and challenges
that no one had ever dreamed of before
for my friend shigeru miyamoto
those ideas began around the woods
in near his house in kyoto
and for my dear departed friend satoru
awada
those ideas led him to invent his first
video game
on a portable calculator while he was
still in high school
[Music]
they both became fixtures
in the history of video games
but first
they were dreamers
and they began with their imagination
so like everyone else
at the start
they were true indeed developers
any awards event
is by definition a look backwards
who's done something great in the
preceding year
but in this category you can look
forward
if you want to see the incubator
where future game greatness is evolving
it resides right here in this indie
category
recognizing brand new independent
studios who released their first game
this year
let's take a look
fresh indie game presented by subway
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right
and the game award goes to
disco elysium
disco elysium also wins best independent
game tonight they're taking home a total
of four game awards
[Applause]
[Music]
so
i'd like to thank all the
great people that came before us
victor choi
and marx and engels for providing us the
political education thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
i've been looking back
looking back my whole life
back to my family
my friends
my son
they say you can't change a person but a
person can change
with time
change of mind change a heart
yeah
that might be good enough for you
but i can change anything
all right surprise there's a second
league of legends announcing tonight i'm
joined by the creative director of
double stallion games lee thomas lee uh
why don't you tell us a bit about what
we just saw uh sure well that was uh
quite an experience
um so yeah we're here it's been an
amazing time keeping this secret but we
are working with riot forge making
convergence and league of legends story
so what is it it's a single player
action platformer where you play echo
echo is a young inventor who has created
a device that can manipulate time i'm
going to send you down into zorn into
the depths of the sum and we're going to
deliver a rich story experience about
the perils and consequences of messing
with time because even if you mess with
it a little bit
you can kind of mess things up huge
consequences yeah huge consequences back
to the future all right fantastic thanks
very much lee great to have you here
great announcement all right in just a
moment five of the nominees for game of
the year are going to go head-to-head in
the best game direction category we'll
see who wins that one and we've still
got some surprises left the game awards
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't know what to put on your wishlist
this holiday
there's a whole new way to play games to
ask for ask for a way to play your
favorite games from screen to screen
stadia gives you magic zappy fingers so
you can turn screens into gaming
machines
stadiu is a gift that won't ever stop
growing
a gift that doesn't take up any space
the gift of up to four 60fps
[Music]
a gift that gives you games anywhere and
everywhere and anywhere and any
everywhere or with wi-fi you can even
ask yourself for stadia and give it to
yourself
get the unthinkable multi-screenable no
downloads no update self-giftable gift
of stadia
one place for all the ways we play
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i know
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
nintendo switch has worlds to explore
and adventures to conquer
[Music]
find your adventure on nintendo switch
and nintendo switch light
we heard you may want to quit vaping but
we can't help you we can barely hold
these protest signs but we can tell you
about this is quitting an easy text to
quit service it's the least and most we
can do
[Music]
my
rated t to m
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on everybody i'm
professional esports host and
commentator golden boy and since 2017
samsung and xbox have worked together to
deliver amazing experiences for all
gamers that's why i teamed up with them
to create something special for the fans
the ultimate ftw sweepstakes and i want
to give a huge shout out to our winner
isaiah yanez also known as buddy roy you
are the winner of the upgrade ftw
sweepstakes you won this killer samsung
75-inch q70r qled tv a q70 sound bar an
xbox one x and 12 months of xbox game
pass ultimate safe to say that's a lot
of nuts congrats and thank you so much
for joining us here tonight now everyone
let's just enjoy the game awards some
more
thank you golden boy and now it's time
for a world premiere a re-announcement
that i think you'll be excited about
[Music]
there was a time when you were heartless
brutal
a monster
and i'm proud of you for changing all
that but
i'm here to ask you to be those things
once more
for them
for me
can i count on you
[Music]
bigby
can i count on you
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now she's an emmy-winning writer and an
accomplished voice actor please welcome
ashley burch
[Applause]
hello everyone
the best games start with a single
person asking a single question
what if
and when that question excites other
people and they start asking what if
it's a snowball of creativity and
passion that pushes games to be the best
they can possibly be
these are the nominees for the best game
direction
best game direction
you called me
here i am
so hard connection
you don't know what you're up against
okay
and the winner for best game direction
goes to
death stranding
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
thank you thank you so much
[Applause]
it was a start from zero four years ago
but i'm very happy to come back to this
stage tonight
[Applause]
i really want to thank a lot of people
who uh started the ship going uh sony
started out with us
uh and also guerrilla for um providing
the game engine and also uh it was a
small boat but all the casts came on
board the musicians the artists the
people who collaborated thank you so
much and also the small boat was all the
staff uh came to work together i would
really like to thank them and also
my family
and best of all the fans who waited four
years thank you so much
[Music]
congratulations today we've got one more
award to present game of the year and
we've got some very special surprise
guests here to do the honors over on
twitter you guys voted for the gaming
tweet of the year we've got the winning
tweet check it out and we'll be right
back with game of the year
[Applause]
[Music]
twitter gaming
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
against all the evil that hell can
conjure
all the wickedness that mankind can
produce
okay
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now she's an actress and producer please
welcome michelle rodriguez
are y'all doing today
i'm happy to be here
there's one last game announcement to
share with you tonight and i'm really
excited about it
allow me to present the world premiere
of our latest expansion to the fast and
furious saga
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm going to split
it's the only way to keep you both safe
i think i know someone who can help
[Music]
[Music]
you want revenge
we want justice
[Applause]
[Music]
when in doubt do what i do
i've seen what you do
that's why i'm kind of terrified and now
need a finish line i'm in my own lane
[Music]
do you want to stay immature
[Music]
or take this to the next level
[Music]
i'm excited for that one
can you believe it's been like 18 years
man
from a little a little article in a
newspaper to a movie to a video game
it's pretty cool
i'd like to now introduce a surprise
guest and also
one of my
friends for life
vin diesel
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
do not tempt me
[Applause]
michelle we
are in our crowd
we have been gamers we have been gamers
forever and we are at an award show
of our people
literally literally me and ben used to
just like literally spend all night
playing like to ken fighter games or
street fighter
[Applause]
yeah this is uh
it's amazing to see that
that trailer finally yeah
i got to tell you a secret too i i i
didn't tell you before
uh yesterday i saw the four-minute
trailer
to fast nine
[Music]
[Applause]
back to you guys
um
[Applause]
i love all of you okay so
[Music]
here to pay tribute to all of the
nominees for game of the year once again
the game awards orchestra
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everything
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and
they keep telling me don't lean down
as my daughter would say dad take over
your fear
um
and
the game of the year award goes to
sakura
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight shakiro shadows die twice also
wins best action adventure game
um
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much
and complex elements that made us a
little unsure
uh when it was about to come out and
we were both surprised and overjoyed at
the reaction that we saw
[Music]
so i'd like to share the joy of
receiving this award with the staff at
from software who pulled out all the
stops to make it happen as well as the
team at activision for their ongoing
support throughout
[Applause]
and finally i'd like to give out a huge
thank you to our players
we couldn't have done it without you and
it was a huge honor to make so
we will continue to try and make the
best games we possibly can
[Music]
thank you so much
thank you
[Applause]
congratulations from sophomore miyazaki
son game of the year for sakiro all
right guys well that's gonna do it for
the game awards 2019 thank you so much
for joining us we'll see you again next
december to keep celebrating games have
a great night thank you very much good
night everybody
you